i will keep this short and to the point  since long before i was on hormones  since before i even  started identifying as gender fluid  i wanted permanent facial hair removal  even when i still thought i was a cis  man i hated this  i don't like how it looks on me and i  hate dealing with it  i've been trying for a very  very long time to set aside the money to  get this taken care of  but between the costs of  other projects  bills  i can't  i have not been able to do that  and i'm reaching a point where i just  whatever i can do to get this done  i've started a gofundme there's a link  down in the description any amount  you're able to contribute is  a massive help  or if you're only able to share this  and the campaign that helps too  thanks in advance